our case energy sent for the clean and
safe energy it's a coalition of over
1,700 organizations and individuals now
who are trying to get the message out
about nuclear energy the truth about
nuclear energy i co-chair it with dr.
Patrick Moore who is one of the
cofounders of Greenpeace and our mission
really is to give people a fax so they
can make an informed decision as i said
before nuclear's twenty percent of our
power today it does not produce any of
the regulated emissions that cause
either greenhouse gases or health
impacts such as particulate matter that
is a real problem with asthma and health
and breathing it's a it's something that
we believe is important and the
interesting thing is the closer you live
to a nuclear reactor the more support
you find for nuclear reactors that's
where people have the information so
cases about getting that information out
about the fact that we need to have more
nuclear reactors if we're going to have
continued to keep nuclear at twenty
percent of our energy as it is today and
that process is going to have to start
now and we need to understand the safety
record which is very good we need to
understand that we have solutions there
on-site solutions now for the storage of
the waste not optimum but with recycling
and reprocessing that will the amount of
waste that's going to have to be stored
anywhere can be vastly reduced there's
an opportunity for an enormous number of
jobs through the construction of nuclear
reactors not just during the
construction but then for the operation
and maintenance and I also believe that
we have a huge opportunity to bring more
jobs in the manufacturing of the parts
that go into a nuclear reactor something
that we haven't seen for a long time
there's certain parts of nuclear
reactors are only produced now in one or
two facilities in Japan and maybe one
other country we can't wait in line for
those behind everybody else who wants to
go nuclear we need to do this ourselves
one of the important things about the
nuclear industry is the opportunity it
does give for jobs and well-paying jobs
they're probably in construction at the
peak it's anywhere from twenty eight
hundred to 3,000 workers needed on site
and
who are needed there to maintain and
operate once they are once they are up
and running and they pay usually around
thirty percent more than the average
salary in the area in which the regular
the reactor is located so these are good
jobs they're highly skilled job says the
whole we have a whole spectrum of
skilled labor that's going to be needed
and today when you see an unemployment
rate of 6.1 percent it is the highest in
five years it's still you know by the
rest of the world standards it's not
that bad but for us here we expect
better and we'd like better and so this
is one way to start bringing more jobs
and more opportunity back to this
country if people are interested they
can find out more about the job
opportunities from the job report by
going to case website which is clean
safe energy org
you